[Music]
I'm a huge fan of what IMAX is about I
wanted to shoot this one sequence in the
format to have a movie even one sequence
of it shot using those cameras you feel
it and it ends up being that much more
fun to watch it's really amazing and
innovative because I remember asking our
DP how it works because obviously IMAX
is the bigger thing so it's cause even
IMAX cameras
I just remember being on set well you
see Finn just in the desert that was the
first time I saw the IMAX cameras
up front and when I saw that logo on the
camera it's true for fans of Star Wars
they'll get to experience a sequence in
a way that they haven't before JJ and
the whole team is so invested on making
this a fulfilling experience the force
it's calling to you just failed in I
think everybody felt very immersed in a
very real world and I think that will
translate to the audience
nothing would stand in our way
finish what you started the scale of it
is so big and the sound is so great it
just makes it more immersive IMAX really
is a powerful engine for storytelling
everything's gonna be bigger and more
beautiful you get drops right into the
middle of it that feeling of going to
the movies and having a fully immersive
powerful high-quality presentation in
the film it's something that is more
valuable than ever and I think that I'm
max stands for that and when you go to
see a movie in that in that format you
know you're gonna get something it is
the best version of going out to the
movie
[Music]